before day before the hyundai ioniq hits
the streets in october explains
Emmanuelle Shaffer you can get a sneak
preview at the generation ionic tour
which kicks off at Frankfurt Shan once
so I leave after that the roadshow will
be moving on to Oslo Amsterdam and Milan
the purpose-built pavilion is in the
shape of the queue featured in the new
cars name inside Auto fans can marvel at
an array of fascinating exhibits and
that includes the engineering powering
the ionic the hyundai ioniq was
developed for three alternative drive
concepts hybrid plug-in hybrid and
probably the most interesting the
all-electric and a real treat here says
Amano is being able to take a look at
the inner workings you can feast your
eyes on the high voltage battery and how
all the components are interlinked
then there's the transmission and the
electric motor itself and this is how
the complete package looks a sleek
design that obviously needs no radiator
grille thereby enhancing the
aerodynamics this car enthusiast likes
the look and the little details Hyundai
has had a lot of people asking for a
test drive from both potential buyers
and other drivers who are simply curious
all you need is a valid driver's license
it's an amazing experience all you hear
are the tires the way it takes off from
the traffic lights with all that torque
really is extraordinary you don't get
that with a regular car visitors from
around the world have come to Frankfurt
skyline Plaza to inspect Hyundai's
electric hatch it's a very very
comfortable Drive yeah I mean skies is
really quiet and you have the feeling
that it get into the speed very quickly
everyone agrees that the hyundai ioniq
is a silent delight
really nice car very very silent smooth
to handle and I still want to see a bit
more in regards to like its compartment
and the grades that are in alpha the
hatch has 350 liters of cargo space hold
down the rear seats and that figure
rises to over 1400 liters the case under
the cargo net contains the charger cable
that can be plugged into any regular
outlet alternatively and far faster you
can use a charging station of course
then filling up to an 80 percent charge
takes only 23 minutes
the hyundai ioniq comes with a choice of
equipment levels all include a
comprehensive package of standard
features from heated side mirrors to a
hill start assist and rear parking
sensors
the interior has a number of stowage
compartments and the front cabin has a
driver friendly layout fashion with top
class workmanship when you start up the
ioniq a display lights up relaying a
variety of stats such as charge status
and range remaining the first version to
be launched will be the hybrid it is
powered by a combination of a 1.6 liter
direct-injection gasoline unit with 77
kilowatts and an electric motor with 32
kilowatts it will be followed in
November by the ionic electro with 88
kilowatts of power and a range of up to
280 kilometers the price tag in Germany
just over 33,000 euros my first time I
Drive an electric car and I'm convinced
that this is the way for the future
it was also this lady's maiden voyage in
an electric car and she loved it too one
thing that I saw educational okay that's
a cool sign and there's another reason
for drivers to go electric
in Dodge City the German government has
launched a 1.2 billion euro program to
subsidize up to 400,000 electric car
purchases through 2020
a paltry 3,000 applications have been
submitted to date but perhaps hyundai
ioniq will manage to give that figure a
big boost car buyers get a financial
incentive of up to four thousand euros
and as another bonus a good conscience
as regards the environment